police are intensifying their search for
a suspected serial killer in Tampa
Florida after a fourth person was killed
there investigators say that six year
old Ronald Felton was shot early
yesterday while crossing the street his
body was discovered in the same
neighborhood where three people were
killed last month
these are treating these cases as
related mark Strassmann is in Tampa near
the scene of the most recent shooting
mark good morning good morning here's
what happened this is Nebraska Avenue
Felton was crossing the street and right
about what that arrow is a killer snuck
up on him from behind several people
heard five gunshots and one of them
looked up to see a man running from the
scene I can tell you at the police
department it's not from a lack of
trying but we're not happy in a
community terrorized by four murders in
five weeks Tampa Police Chief Brian
Dugan struggled to reassure residents
about a suspected serial killer still at
large there are so many unanswered
questions right now melinda ray lives in
this neighborhood where SWAT teams went
door-to-door on tuesday yeah hunting for
the suspect I used to walk all the time
all day all night whenever I wanted to I
know now I walk my dog with my husband
police increasingly believe the Person
of Interest seen in the security video
last month is the same person now
described as the suspect a black male
about six foot two dressed all in black
relatives say Ronald Felton was shot and
killed Tuesday morning on his way to a
local church where he was helping to
feed the homeless
Felton's sister says she warned him not
to travel alone in the area don't you go
nowhere
by yourself they got too much going on
Felton is now the fourth person to be
shot and killed within a half mile of
each other all walking alone with no
motive for their murders
according to police Anthony Knight boa
was just 20 years old Kasim R is his
father
well what's through your mind this
morning when something was like oh my
gosh there's another one it's happened
again Payne bang Bang's I because the
killer strikes and then disappears so
quickly most people here are convinced
the killer lives among them that the
killer is one of their neighbors that
has only increased the sense of anxiety
here and now when it gets dark people
head indoors and they stay indoors
beyond an entire neighborhood being held
hostage by this killer mark thank you